amy what's going on how are we doing hey
john how are you i'm so good how about
you
well i'm struggling a little bit here uh
oh okay bring it on what's going on
okay so um my husband and i we have two
wonderful kids
um we're we really feel deceived and
kind of scared
hey um i'm gonna make sure i can hear it
can you talk directly into your phone
yeah there we go much better yeah yeah
okay so
give me give me a recap okay so um
my husband and i we're so kind of
deceived and scared
um our 14 year old has been sneaking
around
on social media deleting texts and
is being mentally influenced by a church
friend
and so we don't know if we've made the
reigns um
i guess electronics in her life too
tight and we kind of need advice on what
our next step should be
okay so recap here is
your daughter how old is she she's 14
she's a freshman
okay so you have a freshman who's got
access to social media
right does she have a phone and
everything she has a phone yes
so she's got social media she's deleting
posts and deleting texts and
communicating with her friends
and you feel hurt and deceived by that
yes okay so you mentioned something
about a friend
that is participating in this in this
drama so what's the friends role so it
is a church friend who's
13 so about a year younger and
um so just to give you a little bit of
background we've always told our
daughter
that we will always have the password to
um her phone talking talking to the
phone talking the phone
okay there you go um he's never been
allowed to be on social media we kind of
found this out
a couple years ago tried to put an end
to it
and we recently wrote a few texts
from a church friend that
was coming out for her saying that she
was bisexual
and this was kind of influenced our
daughter
and we immediately questioned our
daughter on that
and she kind of broke down into tears
and kind of revealed to us that she was
feeling pressured
so um that that's kind of the negative
influence but we've never allowed her to
be on social media
um and with school devices and with this
phone we've always
had access to passwords and that sort of
thing
so we're we're kind of just feel like
we're treading on in water that we don't
really know how to handle all this
okay um so there's a lot here
but i i want to keep going back to
did you guys get her a cell phone so
yeah mistake one number one when she was
still in middle school in sixth grade
we got her probably the dumbest phone
ever we got
a track phone okay so it was basically
for safety reasons so
she was going to come home from school
be home for 30 minutes by herself it was
basically tech small dad's post
and that was it she couldn't john even
laugh but she couldn't
send this emojis on this phone she
couldn't download apps and we were
very content with it but but now she's
14 and she's got a phone right yeah so
now she's got a different phone
okay and once again we told her you know
these the folks who designed phones
the folks who designed apps the votes
the folks who design
social media the folks who designed
text messaging from the dings
the volume this how the dings hit
to how the apps work to the photos the
way
it the ease the way it reads your
thoughts in your minds before even
it's designed to bypass all thinking
and go directly into your emotional
and fear-based parts of your brain
sure and so i'm gonna hold your 14 year
old and i might get some flack for this
i'm going to hold your 14 year old zero
percent responsible for this
and here's why you can't expect
a child's mind that is hardwired to find
out where they belong
hardwired to find out who's my friends
hardwired to find out where they rank on
the social standing
and you give them a box that has been
designed by tech people and
neuroscientists
to hack that part of their brain and
they get mad at them for not using this
tool correctly
okay it's the mom and dad's
responsibility to put up boundaries to
protect their kids
and so when a child breaks down crying
and says i'm feeling pressured
to participate in any sort of
conversations and here's the next step
the next step is somebody's going to
reach out and say hey i'll send you a
picture if you send me one
or the predatory grown men
all over the world who are scouring
earth for people just like your 14 year
old daughter
they're gonna make her offers that her
14 year old brain can't refuse
because she is a child and so when you
hand a kid
access to earth and earth shows up
access to the world and the world shows
up
that overwhelms and scares a 14 year old
to death
and so yeah she's not making good
decisions but she's a kid
right it's the same reason we don't let
kids drive or smoke cigarettes or buy
beer
or buy guns or what because their brains
aren't ready yet a 14 year old has a
i mean you and i remember being 14 in
our little middle schools right
remember what a nightmare that was you
know what i mean
i just wanted to be cool like on the
seventh grade b team basketball
like team right and there was like 12
guys on that
12 kids on that team not to mention all
the kids on planet earth
right and so i would
never begrudge a 14 year old from
texting with her friends and then hiding
them
or you promise you won't tell you swear
you won't tell that's what 14 year olds
do that's why
that's why they need us in their lives
to protect them i do
understand that that makes their kid
weird and here's how i know that
because my 11 year old came home a few
weeks ago bawling his eyes out because
he realized there was a whole universe
in his school of kids on tick tock and
texting and all
and he wasn't a part of it and you know
what i did
i don't know if his therapist when he's
30 is going to thank me for this because
he or she may make some money off of me
i actually pulled up some of my youtube
show
and some of my podcast reviews and let
him read what people say about his dad
and just the idiots who just post stuff
and his eyes got really big and i said
it's my job to make sure nobody says
that about you
until you're old enough to understand
what you're getting into and that's why
we don't let you have it
and so um in my house we're scorched
earth on it man i'm just not gonna put
that kind of hate and poison into the
hands of a 14 year old
and i know that's going to make my kid
weird and it's going to make him an
outcast and it means i'm going to have
to backfill that relationship right
but i do think it is really hard to put
a
14 year old in that kind of position and
then get upset that they're not using
that correctly
does that make i mean and let's be
honest you know this right
yes so what what changed between
your your um you guys are really tight
on it with that track phone what changed
that you were like ah okay we'll just
give her this other big
bazooka of a phone
you know she's always been um we've
never had behavior problems with her
she's
a you know a great student and we've
never had issues with her so i guess
we decided that we can trust her and you
know she was persuasive all my friends
had one
and we would reluctantly did it um
yeah i love that that's a great question
and listen i don't want you to feel
um bananas 99
of the parents i talk to say what you
just said i know in my gut this is crazy
but i don't want my kid to be the only
one and when i'm calling on parents
is to stand up and be the only one
because what you're going to find is a
lot of other parents it's like an arms
race
a lot of other parents would be all into
i hear this with those video game
systems they walk in and see their kids
playing call of duty and they're like
ah there's a lot of murder going on on
this screen
but i don't want my kid to be the only
weird one and so
it's okay and and vice versa right and
we can we could do this on
and on but especially with these phones
and social media and texting
and so here's how you backtrack you have
a hard hard conversation with your
daughter
and you let them know hey we didn't feel
good about this and we did it anyway and
this was our fault and we're sorry for
putting you in
we're sorry for handing you the keys to
our car and telling you to go drive to
the mall because you're 14.
and i wouldn't beat her up over you've
lost our trust and this
and all that man you put a 14 year old
kid in a position that's really
challenging for them to be successful
and so i would tell them i would own it
all and say hey we set you up in a
position to fail we're gonna take your
phone um
uh we're gonna take social media off
this thing we're gonna
not give you that kind of access to the
world we're gonna want you to have
friends over to our house we're gonna
love that we're gonna love on you we're
gonna be connected to you
um but we're gonna this one's gonna go
and she's gonna think her world just
ended
right think you are taking cocaine away
from an addict
right right or beer away because that's
really what you're doing
and you're gonna have to weather this
upcoming storm and the storm is gonna be
you suck you're the worst parents ever
why do you hate me you're ruining my
life all those things
and now you're playing a long game right
now okay the chances of you actually
doing this are very small and i know
this right i've been working with
parents for
almost two days no no no no no you don't
understand how much
we pay for this is worried but we are 95
okay so so tell me this because this
this question is going to help
all 31 people listening to this and by
the way we're way past that now so i
won't even
exaggerate on this you're going to help
millions of people with this answer
you are already there in your soul what
is keeping you from
just walking in there and taking that
phone and smashing into a million pieces
and say i care for your heart too much
to ever have this conversation again
like what what is the thing holding you
back what do you think's gonna happen
i mean i guess we're scared about
discovering that relationship we have a
great relationship with her
and i think she once
she's also a follower and not a leader
with her friends
and in school and i think i'm just
fearfulness
that um we're just going to push her
away even more
you know and we wanted we wanted to give
her this responsibility and like he's
explained it was
too much we couldn't put that in it was
unfair of us to put that in her lap
so i that's what i guess i'm fearful of
is just
her shedding around all walls already
she's 14 there's a wife to talk to us
about 30 seconds already
right you know and this may be
an incredible opportunity for you to go
first
this may and maybe not but this may be
the first time she's heard you
go first and say hey i screwed this up
and i'm gonna have to do something
really hard i'm gonna take this away
and maybe if you want to be bananas amy
you can lean in and say i'm deleting
social media off my phone would you be
willing to do that for her
yes i would and so if she show if you
showed her delete
social media off the phone and said i'm
in this with you
and your brothers and sisters
everybody's gonna be off social media
and that's gonna means we're gonna have
to like talk as a family blah
and we're gonna have to figure this out
and i'm gonna do something so
cheesy which is i'm gonna have three
questions i'm gonna ask you every day
you're gonna have to go full cheese
sandwich on this one and just own it
you're not her friend you're her mom own
mom
own full mom on this one and
let her know that you're in it with her
and then start asking her questions
and then just keep showing up and just
keep showing up and keep asking those
questions and she's not gonna talk to
you she's gonna
i hate you oh my gosh you keep showing
up and keep showing up and keep showing
up
what i mean by showing up every day you
see her go grab her face and say i'm
your mom i'm gonna hold your face for a
second look her in the eye and say i
love you how is today
what's that boy's name i to hear it
how's your friend who's struggling how's
she doing
did you tell your friend that you loved
her today
put notes in her room write notes
whatever you got to do to
slowly relearn how to connect with your
kid
and make no mistake this is gonna be
hard because you're gonna have to walk
back a lot
you have to walk back in addiction
you're gonna have to walk back what she
feels is her
social connection to the world and this
will be
hopefully one of the greatest things
that ever happens between the two of you
especially if you live it out
it's going to be tough parents out there
follow
your gut a 14 year old cannot
self-regulate themselves
they can't they can't and
these devices are
these companies are preying on your kid
for their data they're building
psychometric maps of your kid and that's
not woo
that's just they put that out there
that's documented and
man there are grown-ups college kids
high school kids who are preying on 14
year olds too
moms and dads your kids need you to be
firm and stand up in this
be the only parent it just takes a
little bit of courage
and then you're going to see people
around you slowly start to have more
courage and more courage and more
courage
and even if they don't do the right
thing remember what your mom said if
billy was jumping off a bridge would you
do it too
i'm doing that to you now you know it
you know it
it's not good for them they need you mom
and dad they need you
thank you so much for that call amy that
is a
conversation that's happening in
households all over the country and so
i'm grateful for your
vulnerability there time to turn around
let's do it